Qu'est-ce que je suis content d'avoir ce métier, qui finalement présente très peu de risques !
Grâce à ce qu'on appelle :
Le montage !
Clément retire les mauvaises blagues, les moments qui ne me mettent pas en valeur du tout.
Les moments, même parfois, où je me décrotte le nez sans m'en rendre compte
Je pourrais par exemple dire une blague extrêmement raciste !
Comme, "c'est l'histoire d'un arabe, un noir et un blanc qui rentrent dans un bar et..."
Là, vu qu'il n'y a plus de son, je raconte de la merde
Mais personne ne le saura jamais ;)
Tout se passe bien !
Bref ! C'est un métier assez safe Youtubeur.
Et aujourd'hui on va parler d'un métier TRÈS dangereux !
Probablement du métier le plus dangereux du monde !
Mais personne ne s'en doute, personne ne réalise à quel point c'est dangereux.
Et il ne s'agit pas des gens qui lavent les vitres des buildings !
Hyper impressionnant d'ailleurs, énorme respect à eux.
Nous allons aujourd'hui parler, messieurs dames, des... Reporters T.V. !
**Meuh**
C'est pour marquer la transition.
Alors, il y a plein de best-of sur Youtube de fails à la télé.
Quand c'est du direct, faut savoir qu'il y a une régie qui gère l'émission.
Il y a le présentateur qui a une oreillette.
On lui dit des trucs dans l'oreillette, on lui dit comment ça se passe en régie.
Et des fois en régie, il y a littéralement le FEU !
Et c'est compliqué pour eux de continuer à travailler, et de faire comme si tout allait bien.
Et du coté de ceux qui sont sur le terrain,
ce fameux moment où il y a un délai !
Entre le gars sur le terrain et la régie, il y a genre 7 ou 10 secondes.
Donc le mec, il y a 7 secondes entre le moment où il reçoit le
"Ok mec, t'es à l'antenne" et le moment où il est vraiment à l'antenne.
Et des fois pendant ces sept secondes, il se passe des choses folles !
J'ai fait une petite...
**bruit de bouche avec ses doigts**
...sélection des moments de live à la télévision
les plus terribles, les plus FATALS pour le reporter !
Et, j'vous avoue que ça me fait sacrement rire !
Allez, commençons tout de suite avec...
Mec ! On dirait une scène d'un putain de dessin animé.
Je pensais pas que ça existait des gars qui se recoiffent de cette manière là.
Regardez, vous n'allez pas en croire vos yeux, c'est parti !
C'est un mec qui filme sa télé déjà, on est sur un niveau de... De non-qualit total.
**rire**
Ca me fait rire, la régie qui a vu qu'ils l'ont mis à l'antenne
et qu'il était en train de cracher des putains de mollards dans sa main pour se coiffer.
Il a fait "Damn it, est-ce que c'est trop tard pour changer de plan?
Ou est-ce qu'on le change quand même?"
Et ils l'ont changé !
Et on a revu ce présentateur télé, qui lui ne peut pas, d'ailleurs, cracher dans ses mains pour se recoiffer.
Car il a la calvitos !
Non mais réellement, vous saviez que ça existait les gens qui crachent pour se recoiffer ?
Ou, c'était une légende qu'il n'y avait que dans les bandes dessinées, dans les dessins animés ?
Mec, jamais de ma vie je me suis dit que ça existait pour de vrai !
J'ai eu une vraie révélation en voyant ça.
Attendez, parce que après, ils re-reviennent sur lui. Je veux voir si tout se passe bien cette fois là.
S'il ne re-crache pas
Oh non c'est terrible, les mecs de la régie savent qu'ils ont fait une énorme gaffe.
Quand le gars s'était recoiffé et que tout allait bien, ils ont pas osé le remettre à l'antenne.
Par peur qu'il fasse une autre gaffe, toute aussi humiliante pour lui.
Deuxième ! Il y a un truc trop drole aussi avec les mecs sur le terrain, les reporters sur le terrain.
C'est des fois il y'a des gars dans le fond qui ne comprennent pas qu'ils sont dans le champ de la camera,
et qui font un truc un peu disgracieux et on leur dit pendant, et tu vois leurs réactions en live !
La réaction de "merde on m'a vu faire ça"
C'est drôle parce qu'il a vraiment pas fait exprès.
Autant y'en a qui font exprès, qui trollent. Lui, il a vraiment pas fait exprès !
Ça l'a fait taper une barre. Il avait trop la dalle, mec, il avait les yeux sur sa pizza, il n'a pas vu l'énorme caméra.
C'est hyper humiliant pour lui.
Ok, ça c'est hi-la-rant. Souvent, y'a des mecs qui vont sur le terrain,
et c'est moins ouf que prévu ce qu'il se passe, c'est moins sensationnel.
Et du coup, il est obligé de faker une situation. On voit par exemple avec les gilets jaunes, où il y a des reporters
qui sont vraiment devant, là où il y a de la casse et qui font "OH LALA, TOUT PARIS EST EN FEU, MON DIEU !"
Alors que, que dalle mon gars, c'est une voiture genre dans tout Paris.
Et donc des fois il y a ce truc là, pour différentes situations,
sauf que lui, il a voulu faire genre que la situation était grave alors que pas du tout !
Regardez, il fait un reportage sur un ouragan, ça souffle un peu. On voit il a du mal à tenir debout. On a peur même
qu'il s'envole et qu'il se fasse mal, quoi. Le gars risque sa vie pour nous apporter des infos.
Et mec !
**petite musique**
Ils mettent le schéma genre "WOUAH ça secoue tellement, ne sortez pas !"
Regarde, on les voit bien derrière ils sont AU CALME, mec !
Il est pas parti si loin que ça d'ailleurs, celui que t'as lancé en l'air.
Vraiment, arrête ! Arrête de vouloir prouver.
Alors soit tu t'habilles en cerf-volant et tu prends particulièrement le vent, soit tu mens totalement.
Bon en vrai, il y avait quand même un putain d'ouragan qui passait sur le territoire,
donc c'est chaud, c'est dangereux et tout...
Mais au moment où tu tournes cette séquence,
y'a du vent, mais tu risques pas de mourir et de t'envoler quoi.
Alors pourquoi en faire des caisses ?
**bruitage**
**rire**
La pire réaction !
**cri de surprise**
J'adore voir la réaction des gens quand ils comprennent qu'ils viennent de faire un truc de merde.
Cette expression du visage... Indescriptible !
Hmmm, je m'en nourris.
Ça ! C'est ça dont je parle ! Ce moment là.. Regardez le  ! **snif** Allez, nourrissons nous !
**rire**
Quel athlète!
Aahh, le cut il est parfait.
Non mais des fois on dirait que la régie est complice.
Genre, la régie elle s'est dit on va faire le switch maintenant c'est okay.
C'est trop bizarre, en fait la régie, moi, je suis convaincu que la régie a sa part de responsabilité
dans tous ces petits moments de gêne là, hein. Elle est responsable !
Ça m'est arrivé une fois, au parc à chiens. J'étais aveuglé par le soleil et j'ai dit :
"Monsieur, ne prenez pas mon chien comme ça", parce qu'elle l'avait pris par le cou, pour le caresser.
Mais en réalité c'était une dame. Autant vous dire que l'ambiance était...
Absolument HORRIBLE !
"On te retrouve pour les sports, Lendric, on va parler de l'arbritage vidéo"
"Ça y est, il fait son retour sur les terrains"
"Oui, y'avait une toute petite incursion l'année dernière"
**Bruit de casse**
**Rire**
"Un accident au plateau"
"Je suis désolé "
"On va demander à notre sponsor de nous evoyer un canapé"
Mec, change de sponsor vraiment.
En plus t'as pas l'air très très lourd. Si un pied se pète quand tu t'assois sur le canapé,
c'est qu'il faut, changer de marque de canapé !
**Musique angoissante**
Pourquoi ?! Toi, qui es derrière la caméra,
pourquoi tu ne lui as pas dit ?
Nan ! En vrai il l'a fait exprès, ça se trouve, depuis, elle kiffe dix fois plus sa vie qu'avant.
Alors ça ! Ce moment là c'est le moment le plus...
INCROYABLE d'un truc qui a foiré en direct.
En gros, il y a eu un ÉNORME problème en régie,
et le mec en plateau il a dû garder son calme. Je vous jure, en aucun cas vous avez envie que ça vous arrive.
Donc l'émission commence. Là c'est le générique de l'émission, BBC NEWS.
Grosse émission, BBC, on parle pas d'un truc indé ou quoi, grosse émission grands moyens.
Voila, ça commence dans 15 secondes.
Ah lala, j'ai hâte que mon émission commence, oh lala, comme j'ai hâte de la voir quoi !
WOUW !
Plait-il ?
Aaah, c'est bon !
Ok, c'est bon... là c'est bon
Ok c'est bon là, c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon !
Bah nan, mais ça on vient de le voir...
**éclat de rire**
On dirait un Youtube poop, mec! On dirait un putain de Youtube poop, c'est INCROYABLE !
Mec, c'est un gag !
Parce qu'en fait, je pense qu'ils ont des boucles, et chaque boucle, elle commence  par ce truc là "Breaking News".
Et donc quand ils changent de boucle, quand ils essaient de trouver la bonne boucle, ça remet le Breaking news
à chaque fois en boucle, c'est terrible !
Regardez derrière, ils parlent entre eux là-bas. Ils parlent entre eux, ils essaient de résoudre le problème, ça se voit !
Il regarde son collègue ! Il y a clairement un gros problème.
Et lui, il attend. Il sait que rien n'est prêt. Dans l'oreillette ça gueule, il attend.
Il se dit "vais-je perdre mon emploi peut-être ?
Derrière en régie, lui il rigole, il ose rire ! Il n'est pas au front, il est pas devant la caméra, il peut se permettre !
Oh c'est duuur ! Personne ne comprend. Qui est le fautif dans tout ça ? Qui est le fautif ?
Ça court en régie ! Ça court en régie ! C'est vous dire le niveau de détresse ! Comment ça finit ?
Allez vas-y, dites moi qu'il y a une solution là. Je veux que le problème soit résolu !
S'il vous plaît ! Ça va commencer, s'te plaît ça commence... s'te plaît la fin c'est que ça commence !
Whoou ! Ah, quel enfer..Ah, celui-là il est dur à regarder. Il est réellement dur, c'est une vraie difficulté.
"Il n'est donc pas présent sur la feuille de match".
Mais putain, mais cette capacité à reprendre normalement ce qu'ils étaient en train de faire, mec, c'est fou !
Cette concentration, ce professionnalisme.
Putain ! C'est clairement pas les youtubeurs qui seraient aussi pros, gros...
"Il n'est donc pas présent sur la feuille de match""
Je suspecte ce gars d'être un robot, clairement ! Un humanoïde robot, c'est obligé.
(Chuchotte) Elle va tomber
Ça va tomber, ils sont trop penchés !
What ?! What ?! C'est des robots, mec, là c'est pas possible, là c'est pas possible !
Ton collègue vient de tomber violemment de sa chaise sur un plateau très dur probablement,
et tu dis une news ! C'est trop bizarre comme réflexe !
Vu comme il est tombé, personne ne t'en voudra de mettre un petit temps de latence dans l'émission,
pour le relever et l'aider quoi. C'est fou mec !
Bon ! C'est la fin de cette vidéo, n’hésitez pas à l'aimer si elle vous a plu, je voulais parler de ce délire là, des live-télé, parce que...
On chie souvent sur les reporters qui sont sur le terrain blabla parce qu'ils en font des caisses et des caisses !
Pas tous, mais beaucoup, parce qu’ils doivent faire du sensationnel, parce que c'est ce que...
Les gens veulent aujourd'hui et faut pas les blâmer pour ça...
C'est pareil sur Youtube, c'est pareil sur tout.
C'est quand même un métier qui est grave risqué en terme d'humiliation.
Tu peux vite te retrouver dans une situation compromettante, ou qu'il t'arrive un truc nul,
et que des milliers, voir des millions de gens, le voient en direct.
Envoyons leur de l'amour, et du respect ! Parce que je vous le dis, c'est ça le métier le plus dangereux du monde, c'est terrible !
Et bien sachez une chose, je suis très content de mon métier une fois de plus.
Je suis bien heureux de décider quand je suis en live et quand je ne suis pas en live.
Ca m'évitera qu'on m'voit me décrotter le nez ou me gratter des choses. Bon voila !
Et bien écoutez, c'est la fin de cette vidéo. Je vous dis à bientôt dans une prochaine !
Grosse bise en tous cas !
C'est ma nouvelle phrase d'outro !
On dit...
Je vous ai dit...
Alors, bon !
On dit...
Je vous ai dit...
Alors, bon !
* Musique *
BON !